in the aftermath when everything had
started to recover and people had more
or less tidied up them
the stock markets had started to recover
from the trillions of dollars that had
been wiped off them Google's network
engineers said that there were only five
people in the world who were able to
approve changes to the most critical
code and each one of those five was
entirely trusted July the fourth in
Western Europe it is right after noon
and office workers are looking at their
clocks and trying to work out if it's
okay to leave early in America they are
clearing up for a three-day Independence
Day weekend over Google's headquarters
in Mountain View are most of the
building is deserted on-call engineers
we at home their phones relative buzz if
anything goes wrong or the billing late
night shifts in data centers location
event of the world there is one well-lit
office tub somewhere deep within the
building and in it is Maria Christensen
our one of Google's most senior
engineers and one of the trusted five
she is against all corporate procedure
rolling out a change to Google's core
infrastructure Cali she's changed only
one session and it's the very first part
of the login code for Google Apps now
this should be an incredibly complicated
function that spins on more functions to
deal with our checking passwords
two-factor authentication third product
as well check suspicious activity
articles freaker's fraudsters and all
the disaster prevention she's changed
just one line of code put it at the top
and it says return true
she bypasses all the red flags from the
automated testing software that says
this won't work this is dangerous this
is broken and instead she marks it for
immediate rollout and committed so
Google's systems properly roll it out
across all of the data centers our
Intel's to coast in North America
over to Dublin and over to Europe to the
Far East and down to South America it
takes about three minutes and what it
means is this no matter what you enter
as a Google password it will be treated
as correct there are no password checks
anymore if you type in the username you
will get it and this seems implausible
if this seems like something that
wouldn't happen remember Dropbox is the
file hosting service used by 175 million
people including I'm fairly short pretty
much everyone in this room in 2011 they
had exactly that security bargain for
three colors now fortunately the person
who discovered it wasn't a Dropbox and
we disclosed it responsibly instead of
telling the world so the damage was
limited but Maria has no intention of
responsibly disclosing anything mostly
engineers that would get notified the
code change like that aren't on call and
those that are have somewhere between
about one and three minutes before Maria
gets around to logging into their Google
account never mind an email notification
they've got three minutes to read it
understand it grasp exactly what that
change means before Maria logs in and
the mobile wipes their Android phone by
reporting to stone
none of the engineer's worked out in
time the risk of doodles trusted five
are still asleep as their phones quietly
it raised themselves so then Maria
emails a manifesto to dozens of new
sites post messages on a few
high-traffic tech forms and then logs
out which is ironic didn't logging out
can actually mean anything anymore gets
into a cloud and don't attach a flat and
assumes the first journalist tests it
successfully the news don't ballistic
the first place - bracelet of all the
web was only The Drudge Report and they
said lighten up because they didn't use
Gmail themselves and didn't really get
it and just went with the story rather
than immediately trying to protect
themselves because that's what most
people did and it covers the followed
people fell into one of
regroups first of all the defenders
desperately trying to lock down their
account desperately try to delete
anything that might link ruminating and
to stop all their other accounts being
compromised because remember if you have
access to someone's email address then
you have access to every web service
they use because they can request a
password reset right your inbox how did
you work at being a defender generally
depended on how good you were at getting
all your other accounts moved away
through that compromised address of
course even the folks who are initially
smart but they didn't use Gmail realized
that other people they email did
Facebook was the first big web service
to react quickly enough that most
commentators suggested that they
actually had a plan in place for this
years before within a few minutes of the
story brethren Facebook turned off not
just password resets but the ability to
log in at all obvious answer that most
people would have their accounts
compromised they just turned it off and
since nearly everyone was already logged
in on their phone and their computer
Facebook rapidly became the trusted
method to contact anyone and that's a
new level of trust that stuck around
after lenders folks looked warily at
email then there were the amateur
detectives those are suspected that the
partner was cheating on than those that
were desperate to find out what my
colleagues are owning or what their boss
really thought of them it was restricted
to email course because if you have
access to someone's Google account in
most cases you have access to their full
search history and all the websites they
clicked on for years and years and years
have you turned it off most people in
this room have it it was described by
one writer is like looking into my
wife's Amma and the divorce rate had a
notable uptake a few months later
meanwhile companies using Gmail or
companies working with companies that
use Gmail just had to assume that all
their trade secrets have been stolen in
the years to come
patent trademark lawyers one made an
enormous amount of money as colleague
Asians flew back and forth between
corporations now the European stock
markets the only ones open on July 4th
at that time went into freefall almost
immediately the Asian and American ones
would do the same when they opened the
next Monday but the most obvious group
if not the largest were the burners
everyone who had any sort of prominent
online presence got their account
destroyed utterly destroyed within 10
minutes any YouTube channel with any
sort of audience found all its work
deleted and vandalized even worse than
the new comment system the UT was
brought in some burners attacked
individual people thoroughly honking to
to white everything is part of a
vendetta but others others just tries to
destroy as much texture as they could
from as many people as they could as
quickly as possible
Google's had backups they did roll
everything back but a lot of third-party
sites vulnerable through password resets
were anywhere near so lucky every blog
with more than a few readers got crude
messages added to it or code that
redirected to shock sites or just just
torn apart destroyed a huge number have
no usable backups so this was the final
death knell for most third-party web
message boards the old ones which been
falling out of use for years and years
as soon as one administrator account
fell the whole site was quickly
destroyed and not many of those ever
recovered because not many of them had
backups some things did work in favor of
the good guys first of all the enormous
rush of traffic trying to fit of people
trying to fix and great things meant
that even Google couldn't quite cope
with the load a lot of folks are
frustrated by slow loading times and
falling servers but certainly it's in at
least some of Google's network engineers
who worked out what was going on and
pulled the plug in one notable place
physically lick
me pulling plugs out of data centers and
uncontrollably shutting down everything
they could someone finally managed to
get an actual proper shutdown command
into the systems that Maria compromised
about two hours afterwards and three
minutes later Google fell off the
internet for the first time in a very
very long while in the months as two
hours of mess this pandemonium were the
people the Maria Christensen was
actually trying to reach she was hoping
to be the next Chelsea Manning the next
Julian Assange the next Edward Snowden
more that she was hoping to create a
hundred a thousand a million people
taking that whistleblower wrong using
the proof hours of freedom she created
to change the world for the better
that was her manifesto that's a
manifesto it was don't find the things
that need to be leaked go through the
files of the corporations and
governments that are destroying our
world show them the light of day have
you was was wonderfully optimistic and
yes some people did there were there
were thousands of leaks many of them of
international importance quite a few
people remembered that the Obama
transition team after the 2008 election
used Gmail until they forget their
official whitehouse.gov email addresses
set up and there were those stories of
billionaire fashion executive putting in
labeling stories about sweatshops and
burying them though so he's a mining
companies exploiting world thing
exposing to incredible danger tale after
Taylor for tale of people putting aside
human concerns and then this phrase got
used a lot team in the best interests of
shareholders but none of those stories
made the news because what Maria
Christiansen hadn't done was manage the
story
what elites its allies always had they
drip fed the stories over months into a
24-hour news cycle that always wanted
more more more but instead in this case
the story was about the process not how
the information be handled at all the
news took was that email was suddenly
insecure that you were a risk that you
should defend
this is how I'm doing them that websites
have been damaged this is how we protect
yourself and watch us because we will
help you so there were no stomach
revelations mustard on the front pages
there there should have been given an
infinite number of front pages but there
were simply too many stories and all of
them are much less interesting to the
public than the question of whether your
partner has seen your browser history
and of course for most people there was
no long term damage at least not of them
personally statistically speaking you
get away with it and sure everyone knew
someone who'd been affected everyone
knew someone who got in trouble but the
chances were that you yourself I've
gotten away with it and one of our high
profile companies suffered slightly
there were no world-changing moments if
dumping untold gallons of oil into the
Gulf couldn't kill BP what could so most
small business has survived unscathed
and the economy recovered slowly having
been damaged no more than by any natural
disaster and gmail a year later had just
as many active users as before because
after all what were the odds of that
ever happening again and it's not like
the government could read all your
messages anyway and no one really got
hurt in the long run maybe it was for
the best that that may have heard
protype you know it all works out in the
end and this side it would be a real
pain to try and switch my email account
somewhere else I'll have to change my
email address it's amazing how much we
trust to single points of failure while
well this is a worst case scenario very
much so everyone here will have that one
Lynch Lee or watch everything else at
least in your online life hangs the
batter you haven't taken for a while or
the email account that you forgot have
access to everything or the password
that your ex still knows but my point is
this even in the face of seeming
disaster when the wall is falling around
when the world is falling around you
remember that eventually this too
shall pass because it takes more than
one single point of failure to change
the world
oh and as familiar Christianson as she
got arrested at the airport after a
flight was delayed because the airline
ran on two dogs
thank you very much up in Tom Scott
enjoy the bustle